Let's go from Texas to Arizona.
One way to avoid cases is not to do any tests.
One way to avoid opinions that you shouldn't
reopen your state yet is to fire the people
telling you not to reopen the state.
And that is what Arizona Republican Governor
Doug Doocy did on Monday.
Doocy said he is accelerating the reopening
of Arizona.
That seemed questionable based on the case
numbers, which, if you look, have a very definitive
upward curve spiking to nearly a new high
yesterday, matched only by the numbers on
April 30th.
So the cases are spiking.
Deaths usually follow closely behind.
And Doocy says let's open up.
Well, income, the public health officials
who say, hey, you know, look at the numbers,
we can't really reopen right now.
Doocy doesn't like it, so he fires them.
Steve Bailey, the bureau chief for public
health statistics at the Arizona Department
of Health Services, says, quote, We've been
asked by department leadership to pause all
current work on projections and modeling.
Yeah, pause it until the pandemic is gone
and then start modeling again how great the
numbers are.
These are the people we should be listening
to.
Now, the timing is suspect.
The timing to me has Trump's fingerprints
all over it.
And it seems to have Trump's pressure all
over it because remember that Trump was in
Arizona on Tuesday and the day before Trump
shows up.
Doocy says, we're going to reverse course
from what I said last week, a week ago.
The governor in Arizona seemed to be taking
the seriously extended the stay home owner
stay at home order until May 15, said stay
at home is working, said the data clearly
point to not opening up yet.
But then this week we learned Trump's going
to Arizona on Tuesday, does a bunch of grandstanding
about reopening and the great governor.
Doocy, who is there and getting the economy
going again.
And just hours before Trump went to Arizona
the day before, Doocy decides, hey, you know
what?
We are going to open more stuff.
We don't need the public health officials
modeling the impact of reopening anymore.
And it has Trump's fingerprints all over.
It's speculative, but it's what we know Trump
does.
Arizona not the only state that is starting
to do strange things.
We already talked about Texas five minutes
ago.
We have reports that Florida or Florida, as
some say, is hiding corona virus deaths by
not reporting the cause of death.
People are dying.
The reporting that a death took place there,
not including the cause of death in the reports
to the media.
And publicly, we have reports that Ohio is
changing how it reports numbers from a five
day to a 21 day timeframe to make it seem
as though the numbers are going down.
What I believe is going on here, and I believe
Donald Trump's past behavior and statements
justify at least exploring this, is that the
efforts are becoming more about let's not
talk about the deaths.
Let's not talk about anything that's going
on medically.
Let's just insist we're past the peak.
And let's talk about reopening.
Let's talk about CEOs and states and all of
this other states of opening businesses and
all of that.
And as usual, the very thing the Trump administration
is accusing others of doing is what it seems
like they themselves are doing.
Some use the term projection to describe this.
We're hearing more and more that the Trump
administration is questioning whether the
death numbers are accurate or whether they
are higher than the real numbers.
Meanwhile, what we're learning about are the
strategies being employed by the Trump administration
and by states to make it a case that the death
numbers are actually lower than what they
really are while insisting that the testing
is greater than what it actually is.
Trump can keep repeating 2.2 million deaths.
All he wants, but he for weeks said sixty
thousand sixty thousand, 60000.
We're now at 75000 yesterday.
Twenty five hundred people died the day before.
Roughly twenty five hundred people died.
At this rate, we will be at one hundred thousand
cases in 10 days.
And it's going to continue growing.
And it's a fiasco.
While Spain, Italy, France, many other countries
have it under control.
Don't take my word for it.
Look at the data coming out of Italy, Spain
and France.
So what do you do if you're the Trump administration
when you've lost control of the situation?
You just lie.
You say the death toll is lower than what
we were told.
And I'm doing a.
Great job and testing is great.
And we're opening up the country.
It's a disaster and people will continue to
die.